à lesquin sont guère montréal emmanuelle
latraverse jetta kambou broc en colombie
britannique
bonjour à vous et michel ces ogm
montréal bon début de semaine à vous
trois bonjour bonjour bonjour
emmanuel pendant que je vous ai dit on
va commencer avec vous ce surplus
l'annoncent ce surplus de presque 2
milliards dans la campagne de monsieur
un peu c'est quand même une bonne
nouvelle là disons le oui c'est une
nouvelle que les conservateurs attendait
et qu'ils ont presque un peu planifier
un faut pas oublier que ce genre de
chiffres là est généralement rendu
public beaucoup plus tard à l'automne
pour monsieur un peu c'est lui qui
permet de commencer peut-être la
deuxième phase la campagne sur des
assises beaucoup plus solide c'est une
chose pour lui de défendre son bilan de
défendre sa vision de la gestion de
l'économie canadienne
mais là maintenant il a au moins un
contrepoids à la récession on en regarde
et finalement ça marche ça va mieux que
prévu on ne sort plus de 1,9 milliard de
dollars
malgré bien sûr les éléments dans toute
l' analyse nuancée de ce qui peut rendre
son discours vulnérables ça le met sur
les assises beaucoup plus solide surtout
à quelques jours d'un débat sur
l'économie
emmanuel vous êtes avec monsieur mulcair
que vous suivez et lui a dit baisse une
bonne nouvelle dans le fond et ça prouve
que moi aussi je pourrais ne pas faire
de déficit
oui ça lui donne un peu de lest je vous
dirai ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
dans cette course à 3 ultra serré c'est
vrai que de plaider le déficit zéro
c'est très c'est très payant pour
monsieur vainqueur face à monsieur
harper mais là où la lutte est la plus
serrée la plus difficile est celle qui
va peut-être déterminer l'issue de cette
course là c'est la lutte pour le vote en
faveur du changement non plus de 60 %
des canadiens qui hésitent mpd libéral
ecce terra et monsieur un mika se
faisait beaucoup attaqué par justin
trudeau sur ce front là il ya donc il
est la marge de manoeuvre de vous voyez
ça va pas si mal que ça met la pression
demeure
très très forte sur les épaules le
monsieur mulcair pour qu'ils présentent
un plan financier crédible avant le
débat alec et michel allex d'abord peu
une bouffée d'air pour monsieur un peu
quand même
ouais c'est certainement une bonne
nouvelle pour lui qui se présente comme
étant un bon gestionnaire des fonds
publics qui fait une grande partie de sa
campagne sur l'économie donc c'est clair
que pour lui comme emmanuel le dise une
bonne nouvelle il le probablement
planifié juste avant le débat de judith
globalement sur l'économie alors
qu'effectivement ces chiffres est
généralement arrive vers la fin du mois
de septembre début octobre m
alors peut-être qu'effectivement du cot
stephen harper en a plus qu'on appel du
pied au ministère des finances pour
qu'on se dépêche a rendu publique cette
nouvelle là mais vous savez une campagne
électorale will à l'as cannes est en
surplus est ce qu'on est en déficit mais
aussi une question de choix des
priorités du gouvernement qui est en
place
c'est pas parce qu'on atteint
l'équilibré budgétaire que
nécessairement les choix qui ont été
faits pour une la table sont celle que
la plupart des canadiens veulent et le
célèbre le débat va être intéressant les
priorités du npd et du parti libéral
sont pas les mêmes que ceux qui venant
après on peut très bien équilibrer le
budget en faisant déjouer ni sont
différents plus progressiste par exemple
alors qu'on sait que stephen harper
beaucoup couper dans les dépenses de
programmes beaucoup coupé dans la
recherche scientifique par exemple dans
l'environnement tant que des choix qui
ont été faits pour arriver cet équilibre
là est ce ces matières et des boys à
succès en campagne et c'est pour ça
michelle qu'on a bien hâte de voir le
cadre financier de chaque partie c'est à
dire une promesse un coup une promesse
un coup non absolument d'abord il faut
dire le surplus de 9 milliards c'est au
31 mars de cette année c'est pas dans
une oeuvre dans l'année courante où la
croissance économique est beaucoup moins
forte alors ça va peut-être aider
monsieur manqué un peu de sa vallée des
taxes et ce n'est pas une si grande
nouvelle pour monsieur un peu que ça
mais il faut voir un plan financier
parce que soyons clairs et monsieur
bancaire mais surtout ceux qui dépensent
plus d'argent quand on a dix ans de ses
promesses que monsieur bancaires vont
devoir montrer comment ils vont faire ça
c'est bien beau d'avoir le coussin 10
milliards de
d'un déficit prévu par monsieur trudeau
mais il faut il faut pas se rendre plus
loin que ça puis monsieur bancaires 8 s
est désirable je vais faire ça dans la
troisième dans la quatrième année du
mandat
ça semble être un peu pousser ça le plus
loin possible
alors il faudra voir si même même si
nous nous publient leurs cadres
financiers ses cadres financiers là vont
résister l'analyse puis à beaucoup de
gens qui vont les analyser oui ça c'est
parce qu'on a bien d'avoir les chiffres
d'ailleurs monsieur mulcair disait moi
je le dépose avant le débat de jeudi
est ce que vous croyez je m'adresse à
emmanuel et alec que les autres partis
n'ont pas de choix que de donner ces
chiffres avant jeudi avant le débat
économique emmanuel mais du coup du côté
du npd on a clairement indiqué qu on
voit le présenter avant jeudi mais vous
savez soyez pas surpris si on retarde
seul le plus longtemps possible on
aurait pu dévoiler sa demain ou mercredi
donnait le temps tout le monde d'analysé
de digérer de peaufiner tout ça si ça
vient jeudi quelques heures à peine
avant le débat ça permettrait au npd de
regarder vous voyez on les a touchés ça
tient la route merci bonsoir et retenir
son souffle du moins pour permettre à
monsieur allait manquer tu analyses
l'idéal c'est toujours de présenter un
cadre financier avant un débat qui porte
sur l'économie pour tout le monde et les
chiffres de chacun des partis qu'on
puisse en débattre lors du débat en même
temps c'est déjà arrivé dans le passé il
est évident qu elle a déjà fait deux n'a
pas présenté son cas le financier avant
les débats des chefs
il y avait d'ailleurs été attaqué le
tube ça n'a pas empêché quand même
remporté plusieurs plusieurs votes donc
c'est un couteau à double tranchant
l'idéal pour les électeurs c'est tout
avoir en même temps en même temps est-ce
que c'est ce qui va tenir la route
jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à la campagne
électorale jusqu'à au 19 octobre
du moins certains très bien je vais vous
faire entendre un petit extrait de
quelqu'un qui a fait son entrée dans la
campagne électorale chez vous savez de
qui je parle on l'écouté on va perdre un
pays qu'on a bâti depuis cent quarante
sept ans qu'il exemple dans le monde
avec quelqu'un qui a oublié ses lunettes
à maison ça marche pas il parlait de
monsieur mulcair il y en a eu comme ça
quatre cinq six exor c'est le monsieur
chrétien qu'on connaît à michel si roger
s'arrête à monsieur tout ça aide la
cause monsieur trudeau oui enfin en
français la compil aux etats-unis a
baissé les grilles de cette mêlée ni
verte j'ai entendu souvent je dois dire
mais est-ce que ça aide monsieur trudeau
dans certaines régions du pays
l'ontario par exemple oui le monsieur
chrétien est très populaire en ontario
les libéraux disent toujours en anglais
les bretagne the good times alors ça
permet de dire quand les libéraux
étaient au pouvoir ça allait bien
d'un autre côté il ya des régions du
canada l'ouest en particulier au cycle
était pas mal moins populaire puis au
québec qui risque d'avoir une autre
couche une couche de plus par dessus ça
c'est grave n'est le sud chrétien
c'est rebrassé le scandale des
commandites s'est rappelé de scandale
des commandites à tout le monde et ça ça
peut être utilisé par les adversaires
alec castonguay monsieur chrétien qui à
dire fin de semaine le npd veut déchiré
la loi sur la clarté on faut pas leur
laisser faire ça donc c'est vraiment
destiné au reste du canada le nom peu au
québec
non le seul parti qui parle d'une tk
nadine dans cette campagne électorale
c'est le parti libéral du canada justin
trudeau le volontairement menées lors
des bonnes mais claims on le répète
assez souvent du côté de la campagne
libérale
on ressort jean quétier pour parler de
la loi sur la clarté il ya près des gens
qui ont écouté cet extrait qui vont dire
je suis pas certain que c'est un enjeu
prioritaire de cette campagne électorale
l on n'entend pas beaucoup parler de ce
débat là on dit que le bloc québécois va
très bien actuellement donc c'est
vraiment une tentative du parti libéral
essentiellement en ontario d'aller
chercher quelques votes pour qui c'est
important qu'on n'a pas l'impression
contrairement à d'autres élections ça a
été effectivement de bois très important
que c'est la tuque les gens vont aller
voter le par rapport à d'autres sujets
la manuelle mais moi je voudrais que ce
qui est remarquable c'est quand on voit
l'entrée en scène monsieur chrétien
c'est vrai qu'on va chercher chez lui la
caution morale d'un premier ministre eut
trois mandats majoritaires qui équilibre
et le budget mais étudiera mais sa
tranche avec tout le pari politique je
vous dirais autour de la campagne de
justin trudeau qui aidé car ni le
changement la jeunesse l'audace faire
les choses différemment et c'est là que
peut-être que le fait de sortir monsieur
chrétiens et policiers au diapason de
tout ce que veut envoyer monsieur
monsieur trudeau et les libéraux comme
message auprès des électeurs en ce
moment il reste 37 jours à cette
campagne c'est à peu près à une durée
normale maintenant voyons quelques
chiffres avant de se quitter si vous le
voulez bien
un sondage nanos ce national dont
canadien et vous allez voir c'est voyez
les courbes l'étendard difficile
d'imaginer plus serré voyez le npd
légèrement en avance les locaux les
conservateurs un peu plus bas et le
parti libéral en lente remontée
ça se rejoint donc autour de 30% 30 29
29 30 31 30
vous mettez dans l'ordre que vous voulez
et puis ça c'est un sondage ekos en
colombie-britannique 25% libéraux 25%
conservateurs le npd loin de 20 à 38
pour sa emmanuel vous venez d'arriver
vous allez me dire mais qu'est ce que
vous sentez en colombie britannique
mais ce qu'on sent en colombie
britannique c'est la force néo-démocrate
jeudi on n'a qu'à regarder les images
hier un rassemblement deux trois mille
personnes pour venir entendre monsieur
mille cas pour tous ceux qui avaient des
doutes à savoir si son pari du déficit
zéro
elle est passée auprès de sa base
néo-démocrate bien il est là le message
et c'est pas seulement à vancouver vous
savez le npd réussi à attirer des foules
importantes dans des comtés comme ici
dans l'intérieur de la colombie
britannique inq sont des cantiques
conservateurs depuis 10 12 13 ans je
vous donne quelques chiffres depuis le
début de la campagne monsieur mulcair a
visité 14 compter ici en colombie
britannique
neuf conservateurs trois libéraux y si
le npd joue vraiment à l'offensive lé si
vous permettez l'ex parce que messieurs
on va pouvoir on va peut-être devoir se
coucher dans votre guitare de toute
façon mais alors connaître l'issue de
cette campagne
peut-être que cette fois ci c'est vrai
on les à chaque fois que mes la colombie
britannique va jouer un rôle clé
michel c'est clair il ya deux provinces
qui sont des champs de bataille dans
cette élection nadia l'ontario médias la
colombie-britannique et c'est sûr que si
monsieur mulcair réussi à faire des
liens comme emmanuel sembles l'indiqué
ça va chaque siège vous êtes extrêmement
important en fin soirée le canton va se
coucher très tard parce que on salingue
vraiment l'on a vu les parties dans un
mouchoir de poche là vers que ça pour
être comme l'élection de 1972 quand ça
s'était joué au dernier compter avec un
recomptage en plus alors ça peut être
extrêmement serré à nombre de sièges
pour chacun des partis les trois partis
très proches les uns des autres
alec il ya plus de sièges en
colombie-britannique à la plus humble
ontario également trois de plus au
québec donc on est dans un ordre nouveau
la voyant redécoupage des
circonscriptions en plus des nouveaux
sièges
on a donc dû redessiner les frontières
de la plupart des circonscriptions au
pays donc ça change effectivement quel
village quel quartier se retrouvent dans
quelle circonscription avec un vote
historique qui est différent donc ça
joue aussi
moi je reviens sur le jeu les chiffres
nationaux qu'on a vu dano cela outre les
trois partis principaux sont à 30% des
intentions de vote
c'est l'égalité statistique là on élit
donc les trois parties sont nez à nez
c'est exceptionnel dans l'histoire
canadienne
le troisième parti politique qui a
obtenu le plus grand nombre de voix lors
d'une élection c'était en 1988 donc ed
broadbent était chef du npd et le npd
avait obtenu 21% des voix
à voir les trois parties à 30% ça donne
des résultats le complètement
hypothétique ne sommes même sucrant la
prévision de sondages d'avoir à quoi ça
peut ressembler en termes de nombre de
sièges 30 30 30 l'heure en termes de
pourcentage ça se maintient jusqu'à la
fin
cette boîte à surprise totale je suis
très content que vous disiez ça mais
celle ci auger pas c'est vrai ce qu'alex
dit c'est du jamais vu de partir une
course à trois avec à peu près le même
score
on sait lire les feuilles de thé
actuellement parce que
la réalité c'est que des courses à trois
ça veut dire que dans un comté une
situation particulière dans 500 votes de
plus à quelqu'un qui gagne ce conte est
là une situation qui n'a pas cours dans
contes et d'à côté alors on peut pas on
peut par procès c'est forcément
l'expression 4 5 400 courses comme ça
c'est pas possible
alors c'est pour ça que il est très très
difficile de prédire l'issue de ce de
cette élection et il faut il faut dire
aussi les conservateurs avaient baissé
au petit peu il remonte et donc
pratiquement depuis le début on a la
même situation de trois parties dans un
mouchoir de poche
on va en voir une longue soirée 19
patrice mais ça va être extraordinaire à
emmanuelle latraverse où vous êtes donc
enlevé prétend que j'allais ou la vendée
ou avec monsieur mulcair
on est à 30 grues 30 blocs plus tôt ce
soir on s'en va vers l'est ce bridge
vous savez tout certains seulement
pourquoi est ce que monsieur mulcair
parle santé dans un coin du pays comme
ici c'est parce que ici le nombre de
personnes à la retraite le nombre de
personnes vieillissantes augmente en
termes de proportion de la population
sont un enjeu majeur mais tous les chefs
converse convergent vers une ville cette
semaine ses cargos riz pour la propre
préparation des débats
alec castonguay merci beaucoup emmanuel
michel c on va se reparler donc toute la
semaine à lek
oui on va se reparler toute la semaine
on parlera de sa doublette surprises aux
téléspectateurs à ce qui vous concerne
voilà vous êtes saluer et remercier
surtout au revoir